[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Gives me great
pleasure to introduce,
Dr. Michael Webster, an expert
in the field of coral reef
science and
conservation management.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL WEBSTER: Well,
good afternoon, everybody.
I'm just going to jump
straight in to my talk
today, and begin with really
posing a big question that we
worry a lot about when we're
working on coral reefs.
And it's this question, which
is, how can we save them?
And the question here is
framed in a particular way,
because there really is a
question of, how can we do it?
And if we don't try,
we actually have
some pretty severe concerns
we're not going to succeed.
And so as somebody who
works on coral reef
conservation on a daily basis
and thinks about these systems,
we're really trying
to figure out,
what are reasonable answers
to this big question?
And I don't know,
has anyone here heard
about coral reefs in
the news recently?
Can I see a show of hands?
Heard anything about--
so pretty much everybody.
Probably had to do with
something like this.
So in the videos I just
showed you a moment ago,
the corals had color to them.
They were browns, and
greens, and oranges.
These corals in this
photo are stark white.
And this is a process
called coral bleaching
that's been in the news a
lot in the last few years.
And what it is,
is it's a response
of corals to really
extreme stress.
The stress usually is that the
water is too warm for too long,
and they go through a
process called bleaching.
We'll talk a little bit
more about this later on.
But what's happening is
that people are really
starting to notice
that something
is wrong on coral reefs.
And it's wrong on coral
reefs all over the world
in many different places under
many different conditions.
And it's really
adding up to what
we see as an existential
threat for coral reefs.
Are coral reefs going
to continue to exist
in 100 years, or 1,000 years?
Or are we doing things
today that's really
going to prevent that?
As a coral reef
conservation organization,
we want to figure out, OK,
given that all these changes are
happening, what
can we do about it?
So what I'll argue
in my talk today
is that there's
really two key pieces
we're going to
have to figure out,
in order to save coral reefs.
To save coral reefs,
we've got to figure out
mitigation and adaptation.
Mitigation here is
mitigation on climate change.
This means figuring
out the problem
we're creating on the planet
by putting so many greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere
and changing our climate.
If we're going to
save coral reefs,
if we're going to
save any ecosystem--
save peace on earth--
we're going to have to figure
out how to solve this problem.
And the good news is,
there's more and more
action around the
world of people
trying to solve this problem.
We've got-- I think-- all
but one country in the world
has now signed onto
the Paris Accords.
That kind of leadership
would have been unprecedented
a decade or two ago.
We also have
communities, we have
businesses like this
business, as well as
other municipalities and
individuals beginning
to take action on climate.
This is really good
news, because this
is one of our chief problems
as a species going on
into the future.
We're going to have to
solve this eventually
to get things right
for coral reefs,
as well as to get
things right for so many
other ecosystems and
things that we care about.
But in the meantime, we're
already locked into change.
We've already put
enough greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere.
We've already done enough
changes to the planet
that we've got to deal with
those changes that are already
underway.
And for ecosystems
like coral reefs,
those changes that
are already underway
are causing really big problems.
And we can't just stop them.
Even if we stopped all of our
greenhouse gas emissions today,
we'd still be locked
into that change.
So one of the key questions
that we have for coral reefs is,
how do we manage that
process of change?
How are the coral
reefs going to adapt
to a changing environment?
And what can we use from the
science of biology or evolution
that can help inform how
we do conservation work,
in order to promote
that adaptation?
That's going to be
the focus of what
I'm going to talk about today.
Before I go too
far down that road,
I wanted to introduce
the primary character
we're talking about.
We're talking about coral reefs.
And coral reefs are defined
by the presence of corals.
This photo shows actually
a whole bunch of corals.
You can see one in the center
that's roughly vase-shaped.
Pretty much every single surface
on the bottom in this photo
is covered by some
form of coral.
A lot of people have no
idea what a coral is.
If you haven't been on a reef,
if you haven't spent time
around them, you may not
have any direct experience.
But even if you have,
what is this thing?
Is it a plant?
Is it an animal?
Is it something else?
Most people really don't have
that close of an intimacy
with this organism.
And I actually want to spend a
few minutes talking about it,
because I think corals are
one of the coolest organisms
on the planet.
And I think there's
some things that they do
that are downright miraculous.
And by understanding
that-- one--
it's just interesting to know
about the corals, but-- two--
it helps us think
through what we can do
to help protect and save them.
So first of all, let's
take a little bit
of a closer look at some coral.
So this is a close-up
of a colony of coral.
When you see a coral head like
that one in the last photo,
it's comprised of thousands of
individual little animals that,
together, constitute a colony.
That colony consists
of these things which
you see in the image here.
These are called coral polyps.
They're the circular-shaped
structures here.
Looks a little bit
like a sea anemone.
So this organism is an animal.
And it's an animal that
lives in this colonial form.
So one animal will settle onto a
reef at some point in its life.
And as it grows, it'll
bud off a new individual.
And then, those two will
bud off new individuals,
and new individuals.
And they build this
sort of spreading colony
of clones across the reef.
And so when you look
at a coral colony,
it might be thousands of
these individual animals.
But collectively, they're
working together as a colony.
Now, in order to
survive, these animals
have figured out a couple of
really interesting things.
You can see in this
short video here,
that there are small
creatures moving around
in the water column.
These are little shrimp-like
animals swimming in the water.
And the coral will be
delighted to eat these.
They've got these
amazing tentacles
with stinging cells that can
paralyze one of these animals
if it happens to
run into the coral.
And then, they can quickly
swallow it and eat it.
They're actually formidable
predators on the reef.
But most of their
energy on a daily basis
doesn't actually come from
being a predator, most of it
actually comes from small plants
that live inside its tissues.
The corals are
basically farmers.
And what they
figured out how to do
is how to grow little
tiny, tiny plants
inside their tissues that
provide the coral with food.
In return, the coral
provides those little plants
with its waste products.
And inside the coral, they're
able to recycle that energy.
And both have a nice place
to live, and both can grow.
So let's take a look
at a cross-section
of one of those polyps.
What you can see here
in the circle blow
up is some of the
tissues of the coral that
show it's labeled
as zooxanthellae
Those are those little
tiny plant-like organisms
that live inside the coral.
They're actually what
give the coral its color.
Corals are naturally
usually clear.
But they have these algae that
grow in their tissues that
provide them with the food.
And the color you see
when you see a coral
is usually those
little organisms
that are providing the food.
Now, coral reefs grow
in places that tend
to be very low in nutrients.
They're basically ocean deserts.
They're in the tropics,
the water is clear,
and there's very little
nutrient in the water.
Coral reefs have had to be
really, really efficient
to be able to grow there.
And one of the things that
corals have figured out
how to do is by internally
recycling those nutrients,
they can be very efficient.
They can also figure out how
to grab space and occupy space
to compete with other corals.
And the main way that
a coral will do this
is by building a
rocky skeleton that it
uses to overgrow other
corals and take over
space on the reef.
You can think about like in
a forest, as trees grow up,
they grow over other
ones and shade them.
The trees are looking
to get to the canopy
to get up to the light.
Corals are doing the
same thing on a reef,
but they do so in a
pretty remarkable way.
They'll take ions
of calcium and ions
of carbon out of
the water column,
and they'll use it to synthesize
what is effectively rock--
calcium carbonate.
And if you look at the bottom
of this coral polyp, then
the cross-section, it's
all white under there.
That white is rock that's made
biologically by the coral.
That rock gives it a
solid place to live.
It also gives it the ability
to overgrow other corals
in that ecosystem.
So in a place where there's
almost no nutrients,
in a place that's
effectively a desert,
corals have figured out
how to grow pretty quickly
and to base their
growth on building
these rocky structures.
So that when you go
to a coral reef--
if you ever have a
chance to visit one--
and you look at the
structures around you,
you'll see structures
like this with huge coral
heads, all these fingers
growing up to the surface.
And all these plates growing
off in the background.
All of these structures are
being built by that process.
They're being built by that
interaction between the coral
and those little tiny
plants inside its tissues,
in order to build these
massive rocky structures.
This is what makes a
coral reef a coral reef.
This is what makes the habitat
for all the animals and all
the other organisms
that live on the reef--
the fish, the
turtles, the sharks.
Everything are
there because corals
are building all of this
structure, which creates
a home for everything else.
Now, most people tend to think
of corals as very slow growing
animals.
And if you were to
sit and watch a coral,
yeah, you wouldn't see much
growth over a period of time.
But with millions of corals
building rocky structures
over hundreds, and
thousands, and even
millions of years,
what they can produce
is actually quite astonishing.
So you don't just get big
coral heads like this,
corals also build
entire islands.
This is an atoll, which is
a special kind of island
found in the tropics.
It is special
because that island
is built entirely out of coral.
And the corals are making
those rocky skeletons
which pile on top of each
other, on top of each other,
and on top of each other.
And in doing so,
they can keep a reef
right up to the surface
of the water that can
exist for millions of years.
And in doing so, the wind, and
the waves, and the currents
will pile up some of
that broken rubble
from the coral over time,
and they'll make beaches.
And they'll make entire
things like this island
here, a coral-built island.
If you pan back further and
look at what corals can do,
they can build entire
structures like this.
This is just a section of
the Great Barrier Reef.
You can see the greenish
colors offshore.
Every single one
of those reefs is
made by corals and just a
few other organisms that
can do this trick of
making rock out of water.
The Great Barrier
Reef is something
like 1,400 miles long.
It can be seen from
space by the naked eye.
This is the largest biological
structure on the planet.
And it only exists
because of these miracles
where coral has figured
out how to work together
with these little tiny
plants in their tissues
to build rocky structures in
a place that would otherwise
be a desert.
So in my opinion, corals
really are the key to the reef.
They build it, they
maintain it, they
provide the place for
everywhere else to live.
The problem we're
facing around the world
is that the corals
themselves are in decline.
And we have to ask
ourselves, what
happens if the corals disappear?
And more importantly,
what can we
do to make sure that
doesn't come to pass?
There's a lot riding
on getting this right.
There are all the
different kinds of life
that rely on the coral reef--
millions of different
forms of life.
It's probably the most
diverse place on the planet.
There's also
hundreds of millions
of people who rely on the
coral reef on a daily basis--
whether they are people who
live in a place like this
and like to go and see
a reef and experience
the wildlife there,
or the people who
live in that place who are
building their economy based
on that kind of tourism.
Whether it's people who rely
on a coral reef for fisheries
and the fish that it attracts
and that can live on the reef,
or islands that exist
only because of the coral
and the reef itself
which protects coastlines
from things like big storms.
And then, the last
thing that's really
super important
about coral reefs
is it looks like a good
fraction of our medicine
chest of the future
is going to be
based on coral reef organisms.
There is huge research
going on right now
to find new drugs
on coral reefs.
They're finding cancer drugs.
They're finding antivirals.
They're finding painkillers.
They're even finding new
classes of sunscreens
that are coming
from the millions
of different kinds of organisms
that are found on the reef.
We all have a stake
in this future.
And many, many
people on the world
have a very direct stake for
their economic livelihood,
and for their food security.
And it really doesn't take
very much for coral reefs
to deliver all of this.
All they need is some
clear water that's warm
and that's shallow, and
they're going to flourish.
Every place in the world
in the tropics where
there's shallow
water that's clear,
we get coral reef formations.
In addition to
that, corals really
like it when there is some
grazing going on in the reef.
There's a lot of fish
and other organisms
that do a really good job
of keeping the reef clean.
In order for the corals
to grow and flourish,
they have to compete with some
other organisms for space.
In particular, they're competing
with things like seaweeds that
would otherwise
overgrow the coral,
so they can grow a lot faster.
Fish like this parrotfish scrape
the bottom and keep it clean,
making a much better
environment for corals.
So it's not a very
complex recipe--
clear, warm, clean, shallow
water with some grazing.
The problem is that wherever
you find people near reefs,
there are a series
of repeated things
that people tend to do that
cause problems for the reef.
This is a photo on a beach
in Maui after a rainstorm.
And what you can
see in this photo
is there's this plume of
sort of orangey brown water
that's coming off the land
and flowing into a coral reef
environment.
That water is
bringing sediments,
it's bringing nutrients, it's
bringing toxins, all of which
are very bad for the corals.
It smothers the coral.
The nutrients bring in--
they cause proliferation
of things like seaweeds.
And you can see in this photo,
there's green on the beach.
That's something you might see
in California, which has highly
productive coastal oceans.
In a coral tropical
reef system that's
supposed to be something
of an ocean desert,
this is a sign that
something is wrong.
The seaweeds are getting out
of control in this system,
this is bad news for the corals.
This kind of pollution-- whether
it's wastewater, development,
or mining, or any other form of
pollution in coastal waters--
is something that gets
repeated time and time again,
when people have
communities that
are based near coral reefs.
On top of it, people
have a taste for fish.
And coral reefs can
support fisheries.
They can also be
easily overfished.
And overfishing
becomes a real problem
when people begin to take
those grazing fishes out
of the system.
Basically, what happens
is that cleanup crew--
that grazing group of fish
that keep the bottom clean--
when it's no longer there,
things like seaweeds
can grow more quickly
and more effectively.
And they can overshade.
And they can begin to
take over the reef.
If you're polluting the
reef at the same time
and dumping a bunch
of nutrients in it,
the effect is like putting
Miracle-Gro on the seaweeds.
The seaweeds can grow.
They can take over.
And if there's nothing
to eat, then you
get this transition from a
coral reef to a seaweed reef.
And when that happens, it
starts to become game over
for the reef.
Remember, the corals are
building all the structure.
They're making everything
for everybody else
to live on the reef.
Once that process
stops, the reef
begins to simplify and
flatten, lose the diversity,
and lose those values.
[COUGH]
Excuse me.
So those two things are
playing out at a local scale.
At the same time, we've got
another set of changes playing
out at the global scale.
This is a temperature record,
average global temperature
for the last century or so.
Everybody knows this story.
The black line here is
average temperatures.
Blue bars pointing down are
years when the temperature
was below average.
Red bars pointing up are
years when the temperature
was above average.
You don't have to
be a statistician
to see what the pattern is here.
The world's getting warmer,
and warmer, and warmer.
And this takes us up to 2016.
The most recent
projections for 2017
are that it's going to be either
the warmest year on record,
or at least in the top three.
The pattern is
continuing going forward.
When the water gets too warm,
it is bad for the corals.
I told you a minute ago that one
of the things that the corals
want is warm water.
They do want warm
water, but it turns out
they're a little bit fussy.
They want the temperature to be
between here and here, and not
above it and not below it.
And the reason for that is
that living in the tropics,
the weather is actually
very predictable.
From one year to the next,
from one season to the next,
it's a very predictable
environment.
And corals over
evolutionary time,
have figured out
how to fine tune
their relationship with
those little tiny plants
that live inside their
tissues, so that they
have it working just perfectly.
They have it optimized to get
the maximum amount out of food.
And everybody is super happy
with that relationship.
But that relationship is partly
dependent on the temperature.
And when the
temperature changes,
the relationship
between the corals
and those little tiny
plants begins to break down.
And what happens
inside the coral animal
is that those little
tiny plants start
to produce toxins that make
it poisonous inside the body
of the coral animal.
In a last ditch effort to
survive, what the coral will do
is it'll actually expel
all those little plants.
It'll basically
throw away its crops
in order to survive from the
toxins that would otherwise
kill it inside its body.
Now, remember, those
little tiny plants
are what give the
coral its color.
And what you can see here is
that on the photo on the left,
the colors are a
pretty orange color.
In the central photo,
they've turned white.
That whitening is
called coral bleaching.
And it's what happens when the
relationship between the algae
and the coral break down.
Now, you think about it,
from the coral's perspective,
most of its food is coming from
this algae inside its body.
Once it expels it,
not only is it already
stressed from the
high temperature
and what's happening inside its
body, now it begins to starve.
In many cases, what happens
is that those corals will then
die.
And if you see on the
picture on the right,
these corals have died
from this bleaching event.
And now, they're fuzzy
and sort of ugly colors.
The seaweeds are
beginning to take over.
This has shifted from
a healthy coral reef
to something that's dead in
a very short period of time.
This is directly
tied to temperature,
and we're seeing
this more common
because the Earth
is getting warmer.
These things, as they're
playing out on coral reefs,
are causing major,
major changes.
You can think about these
changes and say, OK.
Well, maybe this place
or maybe that place.
But if you begin
to actually look
at what happens to
a reef over time,
it's not a minor
shift from what reefs
used to be to what
they're becoming
in places around the world.
This photo was taken
in 1978 by researchers
who were working in
Discovery Bay, Jamaica.
Now in the 1970s, people
weren't really worried
about the future of coral reefs.
Coral reefs were
doing just fine.
But they were interested in
trying to understand them.
And so what these
researchers wanted to do
is they wanted to say,
hey, how does this reef
change over time?
How do the species change?
How does this change?
How does that change?
And one of the common techniques
that researchers will use
is they will go and they will
measure the same patch over
and over again to see
what changes in it.
And so what they
did in this case
is they built a
quadrat for counting
what was inside this patch.
And they put this little
stainless steel pin
into the reef.
Can you see it in
the foreground there
at the corner of the quadrat?
They drilled a hole
into a living coral.
They took a stainless steel
pin, and they tapped it
into that coral so they could
come back year after year,
and they could put that quadrat
in exactly the same place.
Now, that's really
useful to us now
because we can say, OK, what
does that reef look like today?
If we can go and find that
little stainless steel pin,
we can see how this
reef has changed.
Here we go.
Do you see the pin?
This is the same place
30 or so years later.
So here it is where it's
got all of its coral.
This was a very typical reef.
This reef got hit
by a hurricane.
It got hit by disease.
It got hit by coral bleaching.
And what happened
is that in 30 years,
it went from this
thriving ecosystem
that was providing
all these benefits
to the community and all these
benefits to the wildlife,
to this.
Not only is it ugly, it
doesn't provide the structure.
It doesn't have places for
all those animals to live.
It doesn't block the waves.
It doesn't bring in tourists.
This is a huge catastrophe
for the community
that relies on this reef.
It's also a catastrophe
for the wildlife
that used to rely on that reef.
And this is the story we're
seeing repeated over, and over,
and over, and over
again around the world.
This is why we are so concerned
about the future of coral
reefs, because this is
no longer a coral reef.
It's an ecosystem,
it's got some life
in it and different organisms.
But it does not have what
the coral reef once had.
So I might have depressed
you a little bit with that.
The basic narrative around
coral reefs is that one.
And a lot of people
are pretty freaked out
about this ecosystem.
And some people are
feeling some dismay.
I want to shift gears now,
though, and talk about why
we should be optimistic.
Because I think
there are actually
some really good reasons
to be optimistic,
especially if we can use
the information that we
have to make smart decisions
about how we save coral reefs.
And so I'm coming back to
my simple equation before,
mitigation plus adaptation
equals saving coral reefs.
I actually want to dive into
the adaptation part now.
I want to take a
look at what is it
going to take for adaptation?
I'm going to argue that
it's got four parts.
It's going to take making sure
that we do enough work to save
coral reefs at the
community scale
in a way that protects
the diversity of reefs,
protects their connectivity,
and is doing it
at an appropriate scale.
So I'm going to go through each
of those pieces one at a time.
And then, I want
to put it together
in a way that sort of
describes how we're
thinking about how we're going
to save coral reefs going
forward.
So the first piece
is communities.
My organization's
mission statement
is uniting communities
to save coral reefs.
Our specialty is
working with communities
that rely on the coral reef
for fisheries benefits,
for tourism benefits,
for other benefits, who
are trying to figure out
ways that they can structure
their economic
activities, in order
to get those benefits
from the reef
without causing the reef
to decline over time.
The good news is that
communities all over the world
want this.
They want this kind of solution.
They're looking for ways that
they can protect their reefs.
And they're looking
for those solutions.
So what we've found is that
there's actually many more
communities that we're able to
work with who are asking us,
hey, can you help us do this?
Can you help us find
this fishery solution?
this pollution solution?
There is an extraordinary number
of people who want to do this.
This particular
community is in Fiji.
In Fiji, this community
actually owns their reef.
There's a different
property right
history in Fiji, where
the community owns it.
This community
has chosen to take
a huge fraction of their
reef and protect it,
because that's what
brings in the tourists.
And it also protects their
interests for the future.
They're able to
benefit from fisheries.
They're able to benefit
from tourism economy
by protecting their reef.
They found this kind
of solution that's
durable and stable
over time that
provides them with the
benefits and protects the reef.
This kind of system is
replicable in community,
after community,
provided those incentive
systems are there--
provided the interest
in fisheries,
the interest in economic
development around tourism.
That's the raw material
we have to work with,
with many communities
around the world.
When we do this kind of
project with the community,
that community can change
the health of their reef.
They can make it a
better reef for corals.
They can make it
better for fish.
They can address
those local problems,
and in doing so, have more
coral that's healthier,
that's doing better in
that particular patch.
The next piece is we need to
be working with the diversity
that we've got on coral reefs.
It turns out, that
coral reefs-- as I
mentioned before-- are one of
the most diverse ecosystems
on the planet.
That diversity is
really important
when you think about going
through a process of change.
If you think about
corals on a reef,
you can think about
an average coral.
And an average coral is
the coral that's bleaching.
The average coral
is the coral that's
having trouble as
the environment is
changing very quickly.
But the more we look
at reefs, the more
we realize that the
story of coral reefs
is not about the average coral.
It's about all the diversity
of different corals
that are on the reef.
Some corals are already really
good at living in hot water.
Some corals are already
really good at living
in polluted water or
really strong wave forces,
because they live
on reefs that have
had those conditions
for hundreds,
or thousands, or even
millions of years.
The corals in this picture
live in a very strange reef
in coastal Honduras that sits
at the mouth of a river that's
got extremely polluted water.
This is one of the clearest
days ever on this reef.
It's entirely covered
with live coral
in a way that has most
coral biologists scratching
their head, saying, what in
the world is going on here?
How can these corals
live in this environment
where we would
expect them to have
already died and been gone?
The true answer is,
we don't know yet.
But what we do know
is the more we look,
the more of these
unusual corals we find,
the more we find corals
thriving in these really extreme
environments.
And what that tells us
is that there are already
tons of corals
out there that are
able to live in the
conditions we're
creating on reefs now and
the conditions that are
coming for reefs in the future.
So these particular
corals may be
some of the best corals
for future reefs.
The next piece of the
puzzle is connectivity.
That's all great for
those particular corals
in that particular place, but
if they're stuck on that reef,
it doesn't help any other reefs.
So when you think
about that reef
that I showed you
in Jamaica that's
been so damaged by the threats
that have played out there,
how does that risk get
repopulated with new corals?
How does it come back and
become a coral reef again?
Well, if we go back to some
of the biology on corals,
remember, the corals are living
in colonies glued to a rock
on the bottom sitting
next to clones.
That's a very bad situation, if
you want to reproduce sexually.
When corals reproduce
sexually, they've
figured out a solution for this.
And that is they just
release their eggs--
which is what you see in this
video here, or their sperm--
into the water column
all at the same time.
Corals across a whole reef will
release this at the same time.
And in doing so, their
eggs and their sperm
mix together in the currents.
And occasionally, the right
egg and the right sperm
come together and they make
a little tiny baby coral.
Now, that's important, because
it's happening in the water.
It's not happening
on the bottom.
And those baby corals are pulled
away from the reef in currents.
And they might spend a
few days, a few weeks,
even a few months floating
around in the ocean
before they find a reef.
They come down to the
bottom, they glue themselves
to the bottom, and they
begin a new colony.
What that means is that those
unusual corals in places
like that reef in Honduras--
when they reproduce,
their babies can get to
this reef, and this reef,
and this reef, and this
reef, and this reef.
And so if they're
doing something right,
if they've figured
out something that
allows them to
thrive in conditions
where other corals
can't, they can
get their babies who are likely
to inherit that same trait
onto the next reef, and the
next reef, and the next reef,
and the next reef.
So if we've got a diversity
of corals that are out there
and those diverse corals can
get from one reef to another,
we've got the beginnings of
a solution for adaptation.
The next piece of
it is around scale.
If you do something like
this and you protect one reef
like this community
in Honduras that I've
shown on the yellow dot
here, that by itself
can produce that local benefit.
But if that local benefit
can't get to other reefs,
then that system is
going to be unstable.
It's going to get
hit by a storm.
It's going to get hit
by a bleaching event.
And that reef is going
to get wiped out.
It's that process
of recolonisation
at a big enough
scale that is going
to allow adaptation to happen.
So this region in the map
here-- thank you, Google Maps,
by the way--
this region in the map here
shows the Mesoamerican reef,
which is part of the Caribbean.
And it connects
Mexico with Belize,
with Guatemala, and Honduras.
These reefs are probably
interconnected with each other.
The babies from one place
can get to another place.
And so some of the work we've
done in Honduras has said,
OK, let's move from one reef.
And let's start thinking
about putting together
a network of reefs
in Honduras where
each of those reefs-- each
of those communities who
rely on those reefs--
are making decisions
about how to manage their
reef that create a better
environment for corals and a
better environment for the rest
of the wildlife on the reef.
They can get their
local benefit,
they can provide that
benefit to that reef.
In doing so, we can
begin to build a network.
That network of
healthy reefs then
can be a source of baby corals
that can move from one reef,
to another reef,
to another reef in that network.
Now, Honduras is probably a
little bit too small for this,
because Honduras could get
hit by one big hurricane
or something like that.
But it turns out
that the connectivity
is pretty good with places
in Mexico, and Belize,
and Guatemala.
And if we start looking
at the work that's
going on in each of
those other places,
you can start to imagine
a networked system here
where there's enough reefs
with enough communities working
to protect them that include
a lot of that diversity that's
present in the system, that's
connected from one reef
to another.
And it's this kind of
solution at this kind of scale
where we're going to get
adaptation on coral reefs.
This kind of network system
has lots of the diversity, lots
of the connectivity,
and it's big enough
to protect it from risk.
We call this system
an adaptive reefscape.
And it's basically a concept for
how do you build these networks
repeatedly around
the world, in ways
that allow the reef to adapt
to the change that's coming?
So that's the
in-principle argument.
Build the adaptation network.
And the biological
information that's
out there-- the evolutionary
information that's out there--
all says this should work.
And we like that, because it
helps give us an idea of what
the solution should be.
But we wanted to go to the
next stage and say, OK,
can we do better than it should
work based on first principles?
Can we actually begin
to tinker with it
and understand it
in greater detail?
And so we've worked with a
bunch of different researchers
at different universities
to say, can we take
what we know about corals--
how diverse they
are, how much they
move from one place to another,
how good they are inheriting
the traits of their parents--
and can we begin to ask very
explicit quantitative questions
about their ability to
adapt to change over time?
Now, this is a horrible,
ugly set of equations.
And I'm not going to
pretend that I can
explain the equations to you.
But what the
equations have done--
and what the researchers we've
been working with have done--
is they've taken all
of this information,
and they've built a
mathematical coral reef
region that has a bunch
of different reefs,
with different diversity,
with different environmental
conditions that are connected
to each other in the way
that corals are
connected to each other.
And we've used that to
begin to ask the questions,
OK, realistically, the world is
changing really, really fast.
Are corals capable
of doing this?
Are they able to actually
adapt fast enough
to be able to deal
with the conditions?
Or is it a pipe dream?
Maybe they can
adapt a little bit,
but it's just going
to be too slow.
And the pace of climate change
is going to overwhelm them,
and we're going to lose
coral reefs anyway.
Well, the good news is,
the answer looking at this
question-- and we've looked at
a variety of different ways--
always seems to
come out to this.
Yup, they can adapt.
But there's always an if.
And the if is about
what we choose to do now
and over the decades to come.
Basically, the answer
is corals can do this,
so long as we take action
and we try and find
solutions that can
work for those corals.
And that if contains two things.
One, it says if we are
hell bent on burning
every last ounce of fossil
fuel on this planet,
it's probably not going to work.
We actually have to get on
to a reasonable trajectory
on climate in order
for coral reefs
to really have a good shot
at being able to adapt.
The other piece is,
we've got to figure out
this local management problem.
And by building these
adaptation networks--
the adaptive reefscape that
I described a moment ago--
that's going to go a
long way toward providing
the raw material for adaptation.
So if we do those two
things, we have good reason
to believe corals
are going to be
able to make it through this.
So if we think
it's going to work,
can we use that same
information to figure out
the best way to do it?
Because when we look at
doing coral reef conservation
work in a region, we've got lots
of choices about which reefs
should we work on, which
communities should we work on,
which countries
should we work on.
How do we deploy our
resources in a way
that's going to lead us to
the best bang for our buck?
And so it's interesting.
If you go to the coral
reef science literature,
there's a whole bunch
of different ideas
about how to do this.
The basic question
here is, how do you
pick your reefs for the
best conservation benefit?
And so if we're thinking
about building a network,
we could look at
this network and we'd
say, OK, let's find the
best reefs in that network.
And let's protect those.
That's going to be
our best strategy.
So one strategy would say,
go to those reefs that
have really high coral cover.
If they've got high coral
cover, clearly, they're
good for corals.
Those are probably the
reefs you want to bet on.
That's one thing you could do.
There's another
group of researchers
saying, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on a second.
There's a different set of
reefs we should be focusing on.
Let's go to the ones that
are naturally cooler.
The cooler reefs are
going to be most buffered
against climate change.
If we can protect
the coolest reefs,
those are the ones
where the corals
are going to have the
best shot because it's not
going to get as hot.
That's what we should be
doing, climate change refugia.
Oh, that's an interesting idea.
There's another group
saying, wait, wait, wait.
No, it's the warm reefs
we should be going for,
because the warm reefs
are the ones that
already have the corals that
are good at living in hot water.
Those are the ones you
want for the future.
And then, one of the
things that we've
been postulating for a
while is that any one
of these kinds of
strategies that's narrow
is probably too narrow, given
the uncertainties we're facing.
And what we've been
thinking is perhaps
we should be looking
at this as a portfolio
of different kinds of reefs.
That's where we get
that diversity that I
was talking about earlier.
Reefs with different kinds
of environmental conditions
in a diverse portfolio might
give us a better end result.
So we've been able to use that
same mathematical modeling
framework to evaluate
different strategies like this.
Pretend you're God, and you
can design your conservation
network.
And you can design it
from zero, and then you
can play out over time
and see how well it does.
So you can do a
bunch of model runs.
These are different tracks
of model runs for what
performance looks like.
Here, performance is
measured in coral cover
at some time in
the future, model
runs for those
different strategies.
Each line is a
different strategy.
You've got a hot reef
strategy, a cold reef strategy.
There's a strategy that
says, no, go hot and cold.
Put those two
together, that's going
to be your right strategy.
And then, there's
a series of them
that are built on some kind
of diversity portfolio.
There's a gradient
strategy which just says,
just evenly space your reefs.
Don't worry about what's there.
But just space them evenly.
There's another
one that says, look
at how much diversity and
environmental conditions
are out there.
And deliberately design the best
diversity portfolio you can.
And then, the last one says,
just pick them at random--
which is another
way of incorporating
a lot of the diversity in
the system just by chance.
So the kind of results we're
getting look like this.
We've done this analysis
many, many different ways
with many, many
different assumptions
about how corals
can move around,
about how their genes can spread
from one generation to another.
And the answer is basically
always the same answer.
The diverse portfolio
strategies perform the best.
Given the uncertainties, given
the way things are changing,
whenever you try an out-think
the system and come up with
a really smart answer--
it's going to be the hot
reefs of the cold reefs--
as soon as you pick a narrow
set of predicted winners, that's
when your performance goes down.
When you assume that you
don't get to know the answers
but that you want
diversity in that system
to cover your
bases, that's where
your performance is the best.
So now, what we're
doing is we're
taking that kind of
information and we're
overlaying it on real regions.
Remember, this is the
Mesoamerican reef region
in the Caribbean.
Now, we're looking at that
and saying, OK, great.
There are lots of reefs
people are already protecting.
How do we use this information
to identify which places
and what kinds of
reefs we should
be protecting going forward?
How do we build a
portfolio of diverse reefs
that are interconnected
in this system
and are really built on a
foundation of communities
who have figured out ways
to protect their reef going
forward?
We're testing this out
in the Mesoamerican reef.
We're investing a lot
of our time and effort
there because we've got
a great set of partners
throughout this region.
We've got a lot
of work underway,
and we think this can actually
be a real model for how
do you design adaptation
networks for coral
reefs around the world.
But ultimately, what
we're really interested
is in thinking about coral
reefs around the world.
This is the distribution
of coral reefs
around the world in a few
different biogeographic areas.
Each and every one of
these biogeographic areas
includes these same kinds
of coral reef regions,
where people are trying to
find conservation solutions.
And what we're
trying to figure out
is, how do we go from
a lot of good work
that's happening right
now fairly organically,
to really thinking
about how to organize
that work in a way that drives
the process of adaptation
and allows reefs
to have an ability
to adapt to the environmental
changes that are coming?
The reality is that
there is a lot that's
riding on our ability
to get this right.
And it's really pretty urgent.
We've got a few
decades to a century
to solve these problems
because of the pace
of environmental change.
All of the wildlife
that's on reefs--
the millions of different
species from turtles,
to sharks, to
corals, to shrimp--
all of them are going
to rely on our ability
to get these solutions
right and continue to have
coral reefs around the world.
And even more importantly,
people in communities
all over the world are depending
on us getting this right.
And so we feel a really
strong sense of urgency.
We feel a really strong
drive to try and make
sure that we can get
these solutions to scale
all the way across the
world, because our time
window is the one that's
right in front of us.
So I wanted to close
just on one last thought
before we go to questions.
And that is, well,
what can you do?
If you are a diver and
care about coral reefs,
or if you're thinking
about these issues,
what is it that an individual
can do in this system?
The first is individuals can
do a lot on the mitigation
side of that equation.
You can make decisions about
your own carbon footprint
or your own use of
greenhouse gases.
You can also make decisions
through your place of work.
I know Google thinks a
lot about these issues,
around how do they use
energy efficiently,
and how do they develop
the organization
as a good actor in
terms of climate change
around the world.
This is also showing
more and more in policy.
I mentioned that all
countries but one
are part of the Paris Accords.
That one happens to
be our country, which
isn't proving to be
a leader right now
at the national scale.
It is proving to be a leader at
the local scale, and the state
level, and at the
level of industry.
And so there's a lot
of ways of getting
involved in those process
on the mitigation side.
On the adaptation side, the
main kinds of things we can do
are the kind of work we do
working with communities
or other organizations do
working with governments to try
and put in place policies
that allow local reefs to be
well-protected, and
those protections
to exist across these
different networks.
That can include supporting
conservation organizations.
It can also include choosing
to go and visit these places.
A lot of these places are
dependent on tourism economy.
And so if you're going
to be traveling anyway,
I would recommend
go to a place that's
trying to protect their reefs.
Go see those reefs.
Learn about what they're doing.
Learn about those
local organizations.
And see if you can get involved.
You can get directly involved
through those organizations.
through other organizations.
In protecting those
reefs locally,
they're going to add up to
those adaptation solutions
while we get a
handle on climate.
And I'll stop there
and take questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a question about
the adaptive reefscape.
You showed like
a diagram for it.
But have you started
implementing any of it yet?
Or is it just plans right now?
MICHAEL WEBSTER: So, yes.
The modeling that
I described to you
earlier is a project
that's underway right now.
And what we've done is
an initial set of models.
What we're doing is we're
getting an initial set of what
I would call rules of thumb.
How do you design these
things in general?
The next phase is
actually going to say, OK,
let's take a region like
the Mesoamerican region.
And let's map out
where the reefs are.
And let's figure out
what the design should
look like for that place.
We haven't done
that analysis yet.
That's coming in the next year.
But in the meantime,
we can already
take a look at that region
with a screen for what kinds
of things are we looking for.
I mentioned our focus
on Honduras and all
those initial dots in Honduras.
That's because when
you look at the places
where intensive conservation
actions are going on right now
in that region, they're really
focused on Belize and Mexico.
And what's happening
right now is
that you've got this giant
hole in that reef system
where you're missing a
lot of the connectivity,
because those reefs are
well-connected to each other.
You're probably also missing
a lot of the diversity.
And there's some very
unusual reefs in Honduras
that we've already decided
to place some bets on and try
to make sure that
those unusual reefs are
part of that portfolio.
So in general, absolutely, yes.
We're also working with a lot
of the partners throughout that
region-- governments,
NGOs, others, funders--
to think about how do we
get this solution at scale.
And so every step is
in that direction.
The next level is going
to be a tailored analysis
to that particular
region, looking
at the connectivity matrix,
the distribution of habitat
for that region.
And then analyzing that compared
to the work that's already
going on, and saying, how
does the current distribution
of effort perform over time?
And are there areas where if
we expanded our effort just
a little bit, we could get
really big bang for our buck
in terms of adaptation
of the system as a whole?
AUDIENCE: Are we talking
something as big as maybe
transplantation?
MICHAEL WEBSTER: That's
a great question.
I didn't talk about it
specifically in this talk.
But it is an area that's
getting more and more attention
in our field.
And it's a very direct way of
trying to solve this problem.
If the corals are
declining on a reef,
and you want corals
on that reef,
what if you just
grow some corals
and put them on that reef?
And the thinking on
it is very linear.
And we have every reason to
believe that that can be done.
And people have done
it over and over again.
The problem with it
is a scaling problem.
So we did a back-of-the-envelope
analysis on that Mesoamerican
region, which is just
a little tiny fraction
of the world's coral reefs.
And we looked at how many
corals cover a certain area
on the bottom, and how
much habitat, and just
said, how many coral
colonies are in that region?
And the answer ends up
being probably billions.
So there's probably
billions of these colonies.
To do transplantation is
very expensive per unit.
So if you're going
to collect a coral,
you're going to
grow it in a tank,
you're going to run the energy
to keep that tank moving.
You're going to
get it to a size.
You're going to take it
as a diver underwater,
and you're going to
put it on the bottom.
Each and every one
of those corals
is going to cost you
$1, or $10, or more.
Most of the
transplantation experiments
that have been done
so far tend to work
in tens of individual
corals, or hundreds
of individuals corals--
or at the higher end, thousands.
And it's probably
multiple orders
of magnitude off the
scale that's really
going to make a difference
to the population
dynamics in this region.
It's kind of like thinking
about humanity, right?
Humanity has got somewhere
short of 10 billion people.
How many new people would
you have to add to the planet
to really change our
population dynamics?
It's not going to
be a few thousand.
It would have to be a much,
much larger number than that.
And so while I think
there's a lot going
on that's promising on
the restoration front,
there hasn't been a real ability
to solve the scaling problem.
A lot of people are working
at, how do you make it cheaper,
and cheaper, and cheaper,
so that you can do more?
And I think there's
some promise in that.
The other side of it that's
interesting on the restoration
front is that
people are beginning
to say, wait a minute.
What if we identify some
of those unusual corals?
And what if we put
those corals out
there, and essentially speed
up the adaptation process?
Let's pick the winners
for the future.
Let's grow those ones-- like
the really temperature-tolerant
corals--
and put those out on the reef.
I think that's more
promising, but one
of the things that
our analysis shows
on the different
strategies is that when
you start picking a
narrow set of winners,
that's when you start
to get into trouble.
Because that's when
your assumptions are
likely to be wrong.
What you could do, if you
wanted to pick the most
temperature-tolerant corals,
is you could essentially
create a monoculture problem.
You could select those corals
for that particular trait,
but you might be losing
other traits in that process.
We know how to do
this in agriculture.
And this is one of the problems
we've gotten to in agriculture,
is by designing plants
or animals for very, very
specific purposes, they
become bad at other things.
And so you might be able
to design a coral that's
really good at dealing
with high temperature,
but maybe it's
susceptible to disease.
Or maybe it doesn't
do well in storms.
And it's the combination of
these different traits, which
is probably going
to be what we're
going to need for successful
reefs going forward.
So I think we're
just beginning to ask
some of the interesting
questions there about,
can we actually drive
the evolution of corals
by selecting for
particular traits?
And can we do that in a way
that protects our diversity
portfolio?
What I would say is, for
protecting the diversity
portfolio in the process, that's
a really good step forward.
One of my concerns
about this area,
though, is that the
resources we're currently
putting into trying to
solve these problems locally
could shift to trying
to grow corals.
And if we haven't
resolved the problems
that I was talking about earlier
around things like overfishing
and pollution, we
don't actually have
good environments to
transplant those corals into.
So what I would recommend
is let's make sure
that we're doing that work.
Let's make sure we're creating
those good local environments
that are going to allow
corals to flourish.
And if we want to augment that
by restoring corals actively,
let's do so.
But let's not kid ourselves into
thinking that the costs of that
are going to be small
or easily scalable.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So you mentioned
the village in Fiji.
And a lot of us here
have to influence
either our coworkers,
or outsiders, or users
that there is a
better way to do X.
But human nature is what it is.
I wanted to understand
a little bit more
about how you actually go about
from the sort of headline of,
you can do just as well
with tourism than fishing.
How do you actually
implement that?
A little bit more on
the mechanics of that.
MICHAEL WEBSTER: The
bulk of our program staff
are what I would
loosely describe
as community organizers.
They are people who live in
Fiji, or they live in Honduras,
and live in Indonesia.
And they're part
of that community.
And what they have
decided on their own
is that they want to
be part of solutions
that are going to benefit the
community for the long term.
How do they manage
their activities?
How do they have economic
development while continuing
to have these other benefits?
And one of the beautiful
things about working
with that particular population
is that that population
is actually quite keyed into
the interests and the incentives
within that community.
One of the big mistakes of sort
of conservation over the years
has been the assumption
that people like me who
are Western trained--
grew up in North America--
that I better know what's best
for a community in Honduras.
Or I'm going to know what's
best for a community in Fiji.
The reality is, I don't.
I can understand how
coral reefs work.
I can understand what's
been tried in other places.
But the community
actually has to be the one
to think about what they
want for themselves.
The key to making something
like this work usually,
though, is trying
to find the place
where the incentives line up.
And if there's a strong
incentive within the community
to try something
different or to reinforce
something that's
different, that's
when it's likely to work.
And if those
incentives don't exist,
it doesn't matter how
good your idea is.
The community actually has to
be able to benefit from it.
So in the Fijian
situation, that community--
independently, they
knew they had a problem.
They knew that they weren't
catching the fish that they
used to be able to catch.
The fishermen in the community
were saying, you know,
when I was a kid--
and they sort of
realized, wait a minute.
What's going on?
At the same time,
that community was
seeing fishers come in from
other villages and fish
their reefs.
Now, in that case,
I told you there's
a property right system,
where that community actually
owns that resource.
And they started to
say, wait a minute.
This has gotten so bad.
How do we solve this?
How do we take action
for our own reefs
in a way that allows us to
have the kinds of fishing
we used to, and the kinds
of benefits we used to?
And so they came to us
and other groups to say,
can you help us figure this out?
And so we'd seen, for
example, dive user fee systems
work in other communities.
So a community might
say, hey, we're
going to make this particular
area of reef a protected area.
And we're going to
allow it to fill up
with sharks and big groupers.
But if you want to
come here as a tourist
and you want to see
that because you're
interested in that
wildlife, we're
going to charge you a
nominal fee to do it--
maybe $10, maybe $20, and
then you can go and see that.
Well, if you're paying
a bunch to be a tourist
and go to a place like
this, it doesn't really
matter, this small fee.
But those small fees can be
really important to a community
like this, because in the
case of the community in Fiji,
some of those fees went directly
into community projects--
like scholarships for
children, or like building
a new community center.
And that community could
then tie their interest
in protecting the reef with
a direct economic gain.
Those dollars also go
to managing the park.
And so if you can
create a system
like that where the
community is saying,
hey, we want
something like this.
We want a different set of
access to our resources.
We see these benefits
on fisheries.
We see these economic benefits.
How do you design a
system to do that?
Well, we've got good models
around the world of communities
who have been down this road,
who have built these systems--
who have built out
the business plans,
who have built out the
enforcement mechanisms--
so that you can apply those
same tools from one community
to another community.
But it absolutely
requires that initial step
of a community that wants
to do something about this.
It's much more difficult--
and frankly, it's
not necessarily worth it--
to go into a community that's
not looking to solve
a problem, that
says everything is just fine,
and try and impose a solution.
That doesn't make any sense.
The market out there-- if
you're looking for communities
that want to solve these kinds
of problems-- is really good.
That's one of the blessings
and curses of our work,
is that there are
more communities who
want this kind of
solution than we
have resources right now to be
able to help them design it.
If every community has
to do this de novo--
if they have to figure
it out for themselves--
it's not going to
be very efficient.
It's not going to
be very effective.
If we can take what's
worked in other places
and compare that to what
the individual needs
of the community
are, we can find
things that are more scalable.
AUDIENCE: So you showed a
map of all the coral reefs
around the world.
And a lot of them
are centralized--
I saw-- around the coastal
regions for United States.
Yeah, that one.
And then, you had also showed
a picture of the Maui issue,
where we had the toxins coming
in, and also the sediments
and the nutrients.
But not from this
standpoint, what
has the alliance done in terms
of legislation and potential
rulings on that to help
curb those bad behaviors?
MICHAEL WEBSTER: Yeah.
So every nonprofit
organization has
to decide what are the things
that they are going to work on.
And what do they want
to really specialize on?
We have not made a
decision to specialize
on things like legislation.
We actually have lots of
great peer organizations
that work things like the
US national government,
or national governments
in other countries
to try and create
legislation for things
like protected areas,
and things like that.
So our work is much
more community-focused,
which is part of the
overall set of solutions.
It's not everything that
needs to take place.
What we tend to find in
most places around the world
is that sort of larger
scale legal framework
is an enabling condition
which can allow conservation
to proceed.
By itself, it doesn't
usually get us to solutions.
I would say, particularly,
in developing countries that
might pass great laws, but
then they don't necessarily
have the mandate
or the resources
to really implement
or enforce those laws.
What we find is that in
a lot of these countries,
communities can then
use that legal framework
to assert a set of protections
or management systems
over the resources that
are important to them--
oftentimes-- through some kind
of co-management structure,
where the government
will say, gee.
We recognize this is our law.
But we're not really
implementing it.
If the community
wants to implement it,
we'll try and figure out
ways to work with you.
So that's the space that
we work in more than the
setting the legal frameworks
in the first place.
A lot of the countries
we work in actually
have very progressive
laws around this.
If you look at like
Honduras for example,
it has some very
progressive laws
around protecting
coastal resources.
And they've established
very large parks.
And if you just look at that
on paper, you'd say, wow.
This is great.
The problem is that
95% of the work
remains to be done after that,
which is how do you translate
that into a set of durable,
effective practices
that are consonant with
the community's interests,
so that they'll be
maintained moving forward?
In the US-- you mentioned
some of the coastal areas
in the US--
the US has a mixed record on
this for coral reef protection.
I would say in some cases, we
see more progressive policies
sometimes in developing
countries than, say, Hawaii--
particularly around
things like fisheries.
Hawaii has a lot of difficulty
in changing fisheries' rules,
because there's a
lot of user groups
who all currently
access the resource.
And none of them want to
give up that resource.
And that makes sense
from their perspective,
but it creates an ongoing
problem on the reef.
The US does have some big
coral reef protected areas.
Hawaii is interesting,
because a lot of the really
degraded reefs in
Hawaii are the ones
you would see if you went to
Oahu, or Maui, or Hawaii island
and went snorkeling.
Those are the high islands
of Hawaii, which is
where most people would visit.
If you go past
those high islands,
there's actually a series
of atolls that go far,
far up into the North Pacific.
So here are the high islands
of Hawaii right in here.
And then, there's
this Long Island chain
which is sometimes called the
Northwest Hawaiian Islands.
Actually, George W. Bush turned
it into a national monument.
It's called Papahanaumokuakea,
which essentially protected
that entire set of islands--
that entire chain of islands--
which is one of the biggest
protected areas on
the planet, and one
of the most significant
ones for coral reefs.
And then, it was expanded
under the Obama administration.
We'll see if it holds.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
you have basically more demand
for getting your constitution
working with these communities
than you can handle.
So I was just
wondering, what are
your thoughts in trying to--
I guess-- scale
your organization,
or the number of communities
that you are reaching out to?
MICHAEL WEBSTER: Yeah.
There's a number of
different dimensions to that.
One is, we work with lots
of other organizations.
And we have a fundamental
belief in partnerships,
that the Coral
Reef Alliance isn't
going to solve these
problems on our own.
And it's silly for
us to think so.
Instead, we work with lots
of different conservation
organizations to try and get
to this scale collectively.
Another piece of it is
we need to figure out
how to replicate efficiently.
Because if you have to start
over in every place and say,
OK, now it's a new problem--
let's begin from zero--
then you're using basically
the maximum resources
to get the job done
in any one place.
And so we're always
looking for opportunities
to take ideas that
worked in one place
and use them to build sort of
word of mouth momentum, where
the community next
door looks and says,
hey, I want one of those.
Why can't we do that?
And at the same time,
build those tools
that are transportable-- so
that in the next community,
you have a built in
already interest in trying
the same kind of solution.
You've got tools and
techniques for doing it.
You can implement the
same thing more cheaply.
So there's some scalability
that's built around that.
The other piece
is as a nonprofit,
we're also always looking
for more resources
to implement at scale.
There's not going to be
a silver bullet here.
There isn't going to be just a
viral solution that can cruise
and expand all on its own.
At the end of the
day, it is going
to take a certain
amount of heavy lifting
in a lot of communities to get
to these kinds of solutions.
The question is, how do we do
that in a coordinated way that
takes advantage of all
the different players that
are out there, and in
each and every instance
does it as efficiently
and effectively
as possible with the
minimum amount of resources,
so we can apply those
resources somewhere else?
Thanks, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]